There are a few shortcomings in
Diffie-Hellman key exchange algorithm.
First, suppose that Alice tells
Bob to use Diffie-Helman.
The first thing Bob has to
do is to compute his YB.
And this computation involves
exponentiation, which is very expensive.
Therefore, if Alice is a malicious
attacker and Bob is a server, then Alice
can request multiple Diffie-Hellman
sessions with Bob at the same time.
And this would cause Bob to spend a lot
of CPU cycles on exponentiations,
and this can then result
in denial of service.
Second, Diffie-Hellman is only for
key exchange.
It itself does not offer encryption.
And the Diffie-Hellman algorithm does
not authenticate either Alice or Bob.
That is, there's no authentication and
it cannot provide digital
signatures like RSA.